your doctor may perform a transthoracic
needle biopsy or tnb to diagnose disease
in or near your lungs the lungs are
located in the chest cavity between the
surface of the lungs and the chest wall
are two layers of tissue called the
pleura one layer the visceral pleura is
attached to the lung itself while the
other layer the parietal pleura is
attached to the chest wall a small
amount of fluid in the pleural space
which is the space between the two
layers allows the lungs to smoothly
expand and contract with each breath
transthoracic needle biopsies may be
ordered to diagnose conditions such as
asthma
lung cancer
pneumonia and chest injuries before your
procedure you may be given medications
to suppress coughing your doctor may use
various imaging techniques such as a CT
scan or ultrasound to help him or her
precisely locate the target of your
biopsy and guide the insertion of the
needle your skin will be cleaned at the
site where the needle is to be inserted
just above one of your ribs to help you
relax you may receive a mild sedative
and a local anaesthetic will be used to
numb the area a typical procedure takes
less than 30 minutes to begin your
doctor may make a small incision in your
skin where the needle will be inserted
then while you hold your breath and
remain as still as possible your doctor
will insert the needle through your skin
and chest wall you may feel pressured
and then a quick sharp pain when the
needle reaches the surface of your lung
your doctor will quickly obtain the
sample of fluid or tissue and withdraw
the needle
afterward a chest x-ray or other imaging
technique will be used to make sure your
lung has not collapsed the recovery time
is usually very short you will go home
on the same day as the procedure unless
there is a complication